I definitely want to die in the rain.
Soup or suffocation is the same. It
reminds me of the family left behind
[Music] I often cry
rial lisn't you
sch
Of course, I have a lot of such trauma.
[Music]
That's why I
came.
He sent Goofy next to his daughter, and it was
n't enough. One
person wasn't
enough.
Music] [
Music] They got caught.  It is a
place where people come for the first time and receive social education for about 3 months and receive initial settlement support before leaving their place of residence. Here, about
400 hours of
education are
being conducted.
Those who became North Korean defectors to teach them how to catch fish rather than give them rice have a
very low educational level, so it is
difficult to fit into the reality of Korean society, which is rapidly developing in Korean history.  I
thought that it would be part of customized self-sufficiency support to give me a place to work and instill the concept of a market economy.
[Music] Did I
come here for no
reason?  There were
a lot of people who said that, and
people who come to Korea like us
don't know computers. They insult me ​​like this.
[Music]
Lip doesn't speculate about living in
the south because even her daughter's
heating bills are so high.
[Music]
First of all, the most difficult thing for people with disabilities who have defected from North Korea
is mental trauma.  I
think it's hard to understand why only
those who have been through it know  I
have a lot of words, but how
can I use them all? I miss my
mother and
my siblings. I think I will never see them again, so
there are many times when I
cry because I
think I will never see them again.  [Music] [Music] [Music]
[Music]